higher education receives hundreds of
billions of dollars a year of taxpayer
support this is a classic sign that an
industry fails the market test the
nations of East Asia Taiwan China Japan
right Singapore all began educating like
crazy investing like crazy and education
when they were poor they are not poor
any longer
you need college to convince today's
employers to give you the same jobs that
your parents or grandparents got right
out of high school there are very few
social science facts as well established
as the fact that well at educated
countries have vastly higher
productivity than poorly educated
countries only a minuscule fraction of
college grads take a meaningful interest
in ideas or culture after graduation
people attend events like the Soho forum
for fun are really weird welcome to this
ninth debate of the second season of the
cella forum both to those in our
physical audience at the subculture
theater in downtown Manhattan and to the
thousands around the globe who are
watching us on live streaming I'm Jean
Epstein director of the solo forum or a
monthly debate series that features
topics of special interest to
libertarians and aims to enhance social
and professional ties within New York
City's libertarian community were
partnered with recent magazine in
presenting these debates and you can
catch audio of our events on the recent
podcast which you'll find in the iTunes
Store this is an Oxford style debate in
which the audience initially votes for
against or undecided on the resolution
and then again after the debate is over
whoever moves the vote in his or her
favor is declared the winner go into
Soho vote.com to cast your initial vote
you'll find the tonight's resolution
reads all government support of higher
education should be abolished now with
every civil forum we haven't warm-up act
and this evening we are pleased to bring
back Dave Smith who runs the great
podcast part of the problem Dave please
come to the stage and warm us up
oh hello why thank you okay
how are we got a big round of applause
for Jean Epstein uh who's the reason
we're all here at this wonderful debate
serious as the world falls apart we
debate the issues only we care about and
it's a wonderful thing it's a wonderful
time should what's the resolution should
government funding of higher education
be abolished you had me at government
and abolished I am great on board why
would I not want to be robbed to train
the next generations of colonies I don't
know it's just aren't college kids just
the worst maybe I'm just maybe I'm just
getting old but they they they just they
hate everything that's good in the world
like capitalism and white people like
what's the deal why can't you just
appreciate a good thing when it's right
in front of you I don't know maybe
that's a microaggression
I'm not I'm not sure I don't know I mean
we have been subsidizing college for a
long time and it's it's worked out
pretty well
we we elected the brilliant Donald Trump
so clearly this nation knows a thing or
two all right one Trump supporter out
there college is such a goddamn ripoff
that Donald Trump was like I have to get
in on that and he started his own
University where you will probably learn
more than you will at the average
college at least you know to put your
name on the side of a building or
something I don't know Donald Trump is
president I'm still I'm still blown away
by it it doesn't matter how long I said
on the news every day just to make sure
Trump is still president I just need
five minutes and I'm like okay we're
still doing it and then I go back do you
guys I'm a kid I grew up in like the 80s
and 90s and Bill Cosby was the epitome
of success who's the biggest comedian in
the country his nickname was America's
father and now Bill Cosby is like an old
blind rate
and Donald Trump is president could you
imagine if you were in a coma for 20
years and then you came out of it and
they're like so catch me up like what's
been going on since I've been gone
they're like all right sit down I mean
you're probably already laying down but
stay laying down and you're like so
Cosby's a rapist and Trump as president
and you'd be like clearly I'm still in
this coma so like I'm just gonna go
ahead yeah I don't know is college a
good thing I don't know I mean I can't
like my family is uh their academics
like my mother is a PhD and my sister as
a PhD I dropped out and I'm more
successful than all those losers
so I don't really know I don't know what
to say they've never been on TV either
of like they haven't done anything my
little brother is a he's from like my
mother's second marriage he's much
younger than me he's graduating college
next month or actually I think actually
this month three weeks and yeah I'm I
guess I'm gonna stop by but I don't
I hate college graduations have you been
why are they so religious you guys are
both professors why did it why do you
dress up in the goofy robes and stuff
like why does that large moammar qaddafi
have to give the diploma to the students
we're just gonna sing a song and then
participate in this whole down said I
don't know I just thank you it is
exactly kind of like Halloween except
for $60,000 a year it's a very very
expensive Halloween also by the way
college for like 90% of it is just a
place to get drunk after high school I
don't know if you guys have been to
college campuses lately but that's all
it is
I'll say when I went to college the
first you know they have like the it's
like though when you get there there's
like a week before class starts and
that's just yeah it's like orientation
week and everyone just gets hammered I
went out the first night I was at
college I was like who the intellectual
adventure begins and I came back and
there were three stretchers outside my
dorm room
the
his kids had just drank themselves to
half near-death we got they were the
losers who weren't getting drunk in high
school like me like I had already
developed a tolerance by that point and
everything you know there there was this
one kid I remember here's the taste of
college for you okay just the average
college experience so there was this kid
this is uh this was day three so still
no classes but day three of orientation
week and I started I became friendly
with this one kid Greg and then there
was this one weird kid John who just
kind of kept following us around and he
was like a rich kid like a party animal
we nicknamed him cokehead John we
weren't that creative but you can see
why he got the nickname and he was just
a maniac and he would just wouldn't
leave us like he was always by our side
and we're like cokehead John and so he
so this this like three cars pulled up
in front of our dorm of like town kids I
don't even think they went to the
college but they were just like these
kind of tough kids and they pulled up
and then they went into the dorm and
then cokehead John looked at me and Greg
and he goes watch this this is gonna be
hilarious and he goes over and started
peeing on one of the cars and I was like
this shouldn't be college right now like
none of that should be had and then the
kids came back out like way quickly I
don't know if they were just dropping
off drugs at the dorm but they came out
very quickly like they didn't hang out
with anyone and they came out and they
go hey who peed on my car you know as a
reasonable reaction and and Coquette
John looked at me and he goes you got my
back right and I was like no not at all
I absolutely don't I've known you for
three days and I don't even like you
that much and then I I was just like no
and then these kids just beat up
cokehead John and you know I didn't
catch his back at all but I gave a few
like he's had enough you know like from
the distance or it was like is that uh
like then they look at me and I'm like
no I keep kicking them I don't know
whatever you know whatever you got to do
you got to do like I kicked him once
yeah screw him
and then uh and then they got in their
car and they drove off like I guess they
were like we just beat someone up we
should leave they had good sense and
then he got up and he started screaming
at us and he was like why didn't you
have my back back there and I was like
how did you piss on their car like what
a ridiculous thing to do and then he
went this is all true okay I haven't
taken one class yet this is my college
experience and he went in inside the
dorm and he got a knife and he came back
out with his knife and I was like are
you just determined to make this worse
for yourself like what and and he he got
a knife and he was like where were those
kids and I was like they drove away
they're gone take the loss you know and
I mean and and then someone else came up
to him some other guy who I didn't know
and he didn't know and he goes hey dude
what are you doing with the knife and he
goes back off or I'll stab you and and
to which the gentleman replied to him he
said I'm your RA I'll never forget that
line as long as I live you said I'm your
RA John just went oh sorry and just a
life lesson for you kids out there sorry
doesn't cover I'm gonna stab you like it
doesn't it doesn't make that have not
happened in the past it's not like you
could be like back off or I'll stab you
and then go sorry and you go we're good
no problem like we're totally square so
yeah Coquette John got kicked out of
school the next day he got kicked out
before one class he hadn't even heard
like welcome to you know whatever 101
didn't even get that far he just got
kicked out and that was the last I ever
saw coke head John but my other friend
Greg I'm still friends with to this day
he did break into coke head Jon's dorm
and steal his guitar I guess the kid had
a sweet electric guitar and then he
pawned it and and and he bought me weed
for like a week with with the money from
that guitar so like it has a happy
ending as my part all right enjoy the
debate everybody thank you
very much Jean Epstein Dave Smith watch
it listen to his podcast part of the
problem I me a devotee well now for the
main event arguing for the affirmative
on the resolution we have economist
Brian Kaplan Brian please come to the
stage Brian and after the debate Brian
will be doing book signing and sales for
his book the case against education why
the education system is a waste of time
and money opposing the resolution we
have economist ed Glaeser Edie please
come to the stage with with regrets ed
Glaeser has promises to keep back home
early tomorrow morning so we'll have to
leave us immediately after the debate
ends to take a car to the airport so
that's unfortunate but Brian's going to
be sticking around to sign books and to
answer your questions we now close the
voting please take the podium and defend
the resolution all government support of
higher education should be abolished
take it away Brian thank you so why
should higher education receive
government supports there are two main
arguments the first is the economic
argument government support is allegedly
economically beneficial not merely for
individual students but for society as a
whole the second is the humanistic
argument economic effects aside
government support is vital for the
promotion of intrinsically valuable
ideas culture and values if I'm merely
supportive spending cuts I'd only need
to argue that the economic and
humanistic arguments are overstated
since I'm advocating full separation of
college and state however I've got to go
further and I do
my book the case against education
maintains that both the economic
humanistic arguments are deeply wrong
all right
economically speaking subsidizing higher
education is like subsidizing polluting
industries it's probably good these
industries exist but the market tends to
provide too much of them not too little
the humanistic argument is similarly
flimsy while I do share the humanist
ideals higher education simply isn't
very persuasive or transformative the
vast majority college students arrive as
Philistines as our stand-up comedian did
and leaves Philistines I'll leave that
up to you now since Edie and I are both
economists I'm going to focus on the
economic economic argument the standard
story says the college is a great place
to build human capital professors
supposedly spent four years pouring
useful job skills into their students
why should we believe this well because
college graduates out earn high school
graduates by over 70% employers aren't
stupid if college didn't build tons of
human capital why on earth with a labor
market shower these rewards on college
grads this is a very convincing story
until you remember college professors
actually teach oh sure there are a few
majors that regularly prepare their
students for the world of work like
engineering computer science but most of
what college students study is simply
irrelevant in the labor market in real
life how often do you use history
government literature foreign languages
psychology philosophy or higher
mathematics by and large students can
safely forget such materials after the
final exam because it never comes up
again as long as they live and forget it
they do these observations are so
obvious you might wonder how anyone
could deny them we'll just think about
your own educational experience how many
thousands of hours did you spend
studying foreseeably useless material
economists and response is simply to
double back to the labor market if
college coursework were largely
irrelevant real-life real-life employers
wouldn't pay college graduates a
handsome premium strangely though
there's a Nobel prize-winning economic
model that explains why even the most
irrelevant education and even the most
similar silliest majors can be
financially rewarding
it's called signaling basic idea
academic success is a great way to
convince employers that you've got the
right stuff to show off your brains your
work ethic and your sheep light
conformity since people with these
traits are productive workers employers
happily reward people who display them
even to the display has nothing to do
with the job I'll think about it like
this there's two distinct ways to raise
the value of a diamond the first is to
give it to a gem Smith to cut the
diamond to perfection the second is to
give it to an appraiser to attest to its
flawlessness the first to race like
human capital the second story is like
signaling and what difference does the
mechanism make for the individual
student not much for society however
makes all the difference in the world
insofar as the human capital model is
right government support for college
enriches society as a whole by upgrading
the skills of the workforce insofar as
the signalling model is right however
government support for college
impoverishes society by sparking a
wasteful credential arms-race
switch model is right human capital or
signaling the truth is obviously mixture
both in the case against education
however I wriggling share of the mix
exceeds half and probably a lot more so
why should you agree with me for
starters look at the curriculum most of
what we teach in college is so
otherworldly that you're only likely to
use it on the job if you become a
college professor yourself no sane
person in a non nekima job panics
because they'd forgotten everything the
professor's taught them about history
literature philosophy now curriculum
aside you probably already agree with me
did you bother to enroll in college or
pay tuition if all you wanted was the
learning this was a total waste because
you can unofficially take classes for
free at virtually any College in America
there's just one little problem at the
end of four years of gorilla education
you won't have the crucial signal the
diploma as a result unofficial education
barely exists I was supposed to get a
Princeton education without the diploma
or a Princeton diploma without the
education which would you choose
if you have to ponder you already agree
with me
right you already believe in the power
signaling by contrast even worse Dana
Stanton is stranded on an island and you
had to choose between knowledge of boat
building and having a boat building
degree
you wouldn't ponder when you face the
labor market it's important to be
impressive when you wait and you face
the ocean all that matters is skill a
signaling dominates if you look at the
way college students approach their
studies they routinely seek out easy s
professors who dole out strong signals
in exchange for a little work
of course you don't learn very much from
such professors but who cares out of the
final exam you'll never need to know it
again signalling likewise explains why
academic cheating is not only cheating
yourself when you impersonate a good
student
you heard employer so hire you and the
honest students whose merits you
indirectly call into question
academic research reinforces common
sense while economists typically measure
education x' annual return the scholars
who look fine enormous diploma or
sheepskin effects a senior year pays far
more than the first three years of
college combined this is very hard for
human capital theory to explain it makes
perfect sense of college students are
trying to signal their conformity by
completing their degree macroeconomists
to have found that while individual
education is big effects a big effect on
individual income national education
only is a very small effect on national
income now to be fair they rarely
embrace the signaling explanation
instead they usually cry for better data
so we can get the right result all right
but signaling does clearly explain the
results they've got if one laborer gets
more relevant education he outshines the
competition but if a whole labor force
gets more relevant education society's
time and money go down the drain I've
given a small effect of Education on GDP
it's hardly surprising that few
researchers find that education leads to
higher GDP growth you're still trying to
figure out if your machine moves at all
you probably do not have a perpetual
motion machine now the most striking
academic evidence for signalling though
comes from literature on credential
inflation the average worker today is
year's more educated than it used to be
how much of this is because jobs and
we're cognitively demanding how much of
this is because workers now need more
education to get
not do a given job and the case against
education I go over all the main studies
a punch line the evolving labor market
explains only about 20% of the rise in
education the remaining 80% is
credential inflation right you need
college to convince today's employers to
give you the same jobs that your parents
or grandparents got right out of high
school ah this is puzzling dreaming
capital theory why should employers pay
for bas when you only when you need only
high school education to do the job but
signalling explains it very elegantly
the more degrees proliferate the more
you need to stand out when I present
these arguments economists rarely deny
the signaling seems like a persuasive
story instead they usually retreat to AA
priori objections sure Edwards but the
other bad ones the bad ones too all
right and they're almost off it now all
right so they almost all retreat to out
to offer your objections appearances
notwithstanding signaling just can't be
right the most popular objection is just
that college passes the market test if
it were mostly signaling I've heard so
many people tell me someone would have
figured out a cheaper signal long ago
but this is just crazy
higher education receives hundreds of
billions of dollars a year of taxpayer
support this is a classic sign that an
industry fails the market test right
there are probably plenty of socially
cheaper forms of labor market signaling
but as long as these massive subsidies
continue the substitutes will probably
remain on the fringes the easiest way to
discover the no good alternatives is to
end government support for higher ed and
see what comes next
now this point you could respond right
sure education is mostly signalling but
the economic words are so great that
it's still worth subsidizing
but singling aside there's all there
there's still far less to education
second I my rewards that meets the eye
why first college graduates are not
randomly selected most were already high
performance back in high school if the
so they hadn't gone to college they
probably would have been fairly
successful anyway when researchers
statistically compare high school
graduates to college graduates with
equal pre-college ability they almost
always find the true effect on college
on career success is a lot smaller than
it looks
a second standard comparisons focus on
people who actually finish their degrees
but this is totally cheating right to
college graduation for full-time
students is about 50% when you wait
college and investment correcting for
this slashes the expected return once
again now a debate is admittedly not a
good place to do arithmetic
so I'll just say read the book and of
course buy the book first so in the case
against education I snap all these
pieces and many others together right so
and along the way I seriously study
potentially neglected benefits of
college so health crime you name it
because confirmation bias is bad all
right now final result from a social
point of view investments in college
aren't just overrated they're ruinous
subsidizing this rat race is
economically foolish as handing out big
big cash prizes to the world's dirtiest
polluters when the economic case for tax
subsidized College crumbles even many
economists suddenly discover the finer
things in life what about the humanistic
argument the college inspires love of
ideas and culture that refines and
elevates us my quick response a
refinement elevation would be great if
it really happened but the actual data
say this is mostly mostly wishful
thinking only a minuscule fraction of
college grads take a meaningful interest
and ideas or culture after graduation
people attend events like the Soho forum
for fun are really weird and that and
that is why I love you guys all right
now you could agree with every word I
said so far but respond instead of
abolishing government support for higher
education government should use the
power purse to fix higher education we
can certainly imagine a world where
colleges fill every student's mind with
human capital and every student's heart
with Shakespeare so why not do that
simple
defunding dysfunctional systems is
almost foolproof fixing dysfunctional
systems in contrast is horribly hard as
a professor I assure you the entire
system bitterly resists even mild
reforms most professors detest the very
idea of objectively measuring the value
of anything they do they're artists you
can't deal with these people and it's
foolish to try
if someone says you know sorry for
wasting trillions of tax dollars but we
did a few good things and we'll spend
your money wisely from now on the
prudent reaction is to draw a line in
the sand and just say you're fired but
why should we so extreme you know so why
not just cut half and sit and see if
that just a trick
so pragmatically speaking abolition is
just a lot more transparent the scope of
partial reforms is always confusing and
abate able when you separate college and
state you know it since this is the Soho
forum though let me end with my
principled argument for full abolition
the presumption of Liberty I know
there's a wide range of libertarian
views in fact there is one libertarian
view per libertarian but we should all
be able to agree that the burden of
proof rests on the advocates of
government intervention if politicians
are going to take our money without our
consent they should at least have solid
prove the money is very well spent
government support for college does not
meet that bar not even close
thank you
[Applause]
a pleasure for the negative take it away
ed thank you and I'm really grateful
gene that you brought together a really
wide ideological perspective really
running from A to B all the way because
because I favored cutting all spending
on education except for one guy who's
really deserving who should get a Pell
Grant so so we're other the other than
that we're no I mean it's there's a lot
of truth in what Brian said and there's
a great public service that he has done
in poking holes in the educational
establishment um I do think as in many
cases the need is at least as much for
reform as simply cutting spending but I
agree with Brian that that reform is
hard but when I look at all the universe
of crazy things that the government does
the combination of Pell grants and a
certain amount of of university based
research funding NIH some NSF funding
these are by far these aren't the
Detroit people mover monorail okay these
these are much better more socially
productive things than those so when I
when I think about going through things
this is not the first place that I would
massively take an axe to but still some
axe cutting would be appropriate now the
biggest factual disagreement that Brian
and I have is on the statement and you
heard him make it that cross nationally
there's no relationship between
schooling and earnings I just can't see
how that comes out of the data let me
just give you a few facts on this when
you look across countries and you
compare the top quarter by years of
schooling of countries with the bottom
quarter the top quarter has average
earnings of $34,000 the bottom quarter
has average earnings of $1,200 in fact
there are very few social science facts
as well established as the fact that
well at educated countries have vastly
higher productivity than poorly educated
countries a typical estimate is that the
extra year of schooling that the country
level is associated with 42 percent more
productivity at the country level which
is not less than the individual earnings
but four times those individual earnings
and the correlation coefficient across
countries between earnings and education
is a whopping 78 percent now if you did
this in growth so look at change in
education and change in earnings you
take the top quarter in terms of growth
in education that had an average per
capita growth and earnings of 474
percent the bottom quarter between 1960
and 2010 the bottom quarter growth of
125 percent so almost
fourfold growth difference year-on-year
the year-to-year earnings every extra
year of growth that you had an extra
thirty two percent in terms of earnings
so triple the individual earnings number
now if you take just 1960 schooling and
look at subsequent growth the top
quarter in terms of schooling three
hundred and eighty eight percent average
income growth the bottom quarter twenty
three percent average earnings growth so
Brian has numbers like you know one
typical estimate is that a year of
schooling boosts national income by from
1.3 to 1.7 percent now Brian I love you
but those numbers aren't even typical at
the table you took them from right
because in fact the other three numbers
in that table are six point six six
point nine and eight point three percent
which are between five and six times the
numbers that you actually sight on this
so the the it's not that there isn't a
macro literature that is interested in
what schooling does to total factor
productivity growth and that literature
as Brian correctly States is deeply
mixed but total factor productivity
growth is essentially GDP already
controlling for the direct effect of
schooling which is understood to be
quite significant and positive now Brian
correctly then says well if you did find
a positive effect and of course you do
and it's huge
you could then say well maybe that's
reverse causality and maybe it is right
quite possibly but when we look at
whether or not income in 1960 predicts
schooling growth right the answer is it
doesn't
whereas schooling in 1960 Wapping lee
predicts income growth subsequently so
it's not that I think this makes the
case for the current educational
establishment nonsense but you know it's
very hard to look at that and say to
yourself that this is obviously the
winner for for signaling and certainly
you know for example the claim that he
makes on page 122 that that you know the
fact that individual schooling has such
a higher return than national schooling
given that I think the direct evidence
shows exactly the opposite far from
suggesting that signaling wins this
round
I think signaling losses based on on the
the massively higher macro estimate
those macro estimates are also larger
when you look at the metro area level
rather than the the individual level so
typically when economists look at metro
area relationships between schooling and
area income or success they're pretty
large effects one year of one extra
percentage point or ten extra percentage
points of adults with a college
we are associated with about 15% higher
median earnings at the metro area level
the typical human capital estimates are
that a 10% increase in the share of the
population with a college degree in your
metro area is associated with 10 percent
higher earnings for you holding your
years of schooling constant that's from
the work of Enrico Moretti or if you
wanted to compare population growth
between 1960 and 2010 for the most
educated quarter versus the least
educated quarter of America's cities 117
percent population growth for the most
educated sixty percent for the least
educated another way of making this real
is if you want to think to yourself
do we understand why Seattle in Detroit
looked different when they in the 1970s
they both looked like declining
industrial towns and to Joker's in 1971
put up a billboard on the highway
leaving Seattle asking the last person
to leave the city to please turn out the
lights right because you know no one
could imagine a Seattle with a smaller
smaller Boeing and Boeing even cutting
back on jobs before Amazon Costco
Microsoft Starbucks right the difference
is completely explained by the education
level of the of the residents of these
two cities they're both exactly on the
regression line more than 50% of
Seattle's adults have college degrees
about one in eight of Detroit's adults
have college degrees now this doesn't
mean that I don't believe in signaling I
think a lot of the sheepskin effect is
is signaling absolutely and I think it's
true that labor economists have
underestimated signaling I think Ryan is
exactly right on that I do think the
sheepskin effect does probably have some
just straight ability bias as well I
mean you know the kid who wastes four
years of his parents savings going to
NYU and then doesn't bother to show up
for the degree right there's something
wrong with that kid okay you know I top
of the fact that is like dad's chasing
him with a whip - or something like that
now when we actually ask ourselves what
what is so this is all at a very high
level as indeed Brian's discussion is
and notice I'm not even dignifying the
humanist argument with response so I
want that I want that noted in part just
to be clear it's not that I don't
believe in the uplifting values of
certain types of education but if
something does uplift the soul I want
the government as far away from it as
possible okay so it's it's far from now
what are the three possible you know
justifications that I think are
reasonable the first is spill overs the
public good nature of knowledge okay so
for 25 years Paul Milgram has been
helping the FCC design spectrum auctions
most recently
the incentive auction which Paul
designed based on NSF supported research
involved essentially a trade of spectrum
so no public stuff was given away it's a
trade of spectrum from broadcast
broadcaster to mobile broadband
providers that netted nine billion
dollars for the US government just by a
well-designed auction right that nine
billion dollars that covers the entire
expenditure of econ research by the NSF
since the dawn of time okay so it's this
is a small thing and they're people
believe it or not lean on economics
fields who also think their research has
social value added like these medical
guys the so I think there's a reasonable
view for some limited public supporting
of research in core areas to the area of
Pell grants community colleges area of
support for the most disadvantaged
Americans in which we're not
fundamentally making the case based on
externalities or inefficiencies we're
making the case on social justice I
don't know a better way of trying to
support poor kids other than trying to
get them somewhat better better
schooling now it is true that our
current schooling products are failing
our kids it is absolutely right that
Brian is arguing for better vocational
training and indeed that's the hope the
community colleges can be doing a better
job on this and remember more than 50%
of Pell grants are going to private
universities which are at least are
allegedly claiming to be delivering some
degree of usable skills but I just have
absolutely no trouble when I think about
all the ways the government tries to
redistribute money to try and make
America a more equitable place or even
more importantly right given that I care
far more about inequality of opportunity
than I do a better quality of outcomes a
place in which which kids from poor
backgrounds can find some degree of
possibility I just have no problem with
the idea that we're gonna have some
limited public support for schooling for
poor children it just doesn't it just
doesn't bother me at all and I think
it's a totally reasonable thing for
there for the government to be doing now
you can tell me that we want to rethink
the Pell Grant program you can tell me
that we want to rethink school loans you
can tell me that you want to rethink the
way of community colleges operate I have
a hundred percent with you okay but I'm
not in a place that says that I want to
get rid of all of public support for
poorer kids to get to get more education
I just I'm not there I'm not going to be
there quite honestly I think that that's
something that makes America that the
very idea that makes America something
of a better place
remember the the Pell grants two-thirds
of unmarried undergraduates with with
kids are receiving Pell grants so these
are people are going through somewhat of
a tough life and it's not a terrible
thing that they're getting a bit of a
bit of support
um third this is the this is the hard oh
just one point on telegram so one of the
things that I think is is attractive
about the idea of keeping some degree of
federal support is we can make greater
demands of the community colleges if we
keep some federal funding in the game so
if we make pell grant payments
conditional upon employment for the
people receive the education this can
provide stronger incentives for the
schools to provide it we can actually in
some sense use some degree of federal
engagement to to block it to push them
towards a more productive space finally
I have some sympathy and this relates to
the facts with which I began mr. Thomas
Jefferson's line that if a nation
expects to be ignorant and free in a
state of civilization it expects what
never was and never will be
now I don't know the extent to which
this necessarily calls for the large and
bloated federal education infrastructure
that we currently have but somehow or
other the idea of turning our back on
higher education from the public sphere
doesn't that sound entirely right to me
either that I would have guessed that if
we're going to get a nation that is
smarter that is better educated is more
functional that almost assuredly this
will require some version of using
everything that we have now this
requires above all parents all right and
it requires communities and it requires
people like Brian to yell and scream at
this guy's and say what's so bloody
wrong about all this and while you're
teaching junk toward our kids and why
nobody is learning all this is 100% true
but I think the end of the day you're
still gonna want some degree of national
public support for schools for for
education so let me let me just wrap it
up there which is when I look at
communities along many different
dimensions corruption right there's a
strong negative current correlation
between education and corruption when we
look at you know the the misery the
opioid abuse that occurs in the eastern
heartland of the US where joblessness is
extreme all of these places are places
which are enormously sparse on education
I see very few things at the community
level that do better when there are
fewer college graduates and as a result
if I thought
all the stupid things that the federal
government does why is this the one that
I would Center on first to God
relative to I don't know People Mover
mana rails or our highways and bridges
to nowhere or any number of the other
crazy things that the government does so
let me just end there and just say you
know I'm grateful for Brian's book I am
grateful that we're having this debate I
think that there is much to be sought in
terms of education reform but I do think
that by and large the right answer is
not to give up on education not even to
give up on some public support of
Education that indeed both as a tool for
funding knowledge creation and as a tool
for allowing some degree of economic
opportunity and in some sense to make
sure the glue of the nation sticks
together some degree of intervention
even if it is just one Pell Grant for
one guy in Cleveland right some degree
of public intervention makes sense thank
you from Brian you might want to take
the podium Brian gets a rebuttal and
then it gets a rebuttal then we go to
questions so great pleasure debate with
Ed because his arguments are different
from those of any of the other critics
so the most technical one is one we're
really you do need to read the book to
decide for yourself but this is on the
question of is the National payoff for
education greater than equal to or
smaller than the individual payoff all I
can say here is that when I started
writing the book I thought I was gonna
have to deal with the stuff that adds to
hold you and then when I actually read
the paper said oh wow
actually they already agree with me so
this is much easier than I was expecting
you know so we can the you know the
stuff that Ed was saying I don't think
it's so much wrong as just that people
actually do the research would never do
such a simple comparison and instead
they would go and say well let's go and
adjust for a few other things and after
they adjust for a few other things
that's where they have the trouble
finding any noticeable fact of education
but again so that's one where I just
encourage you to read the book that's
the best place to resolve it hard to do
it here so why don't we just go over
edge top three arguments for continuing
to have some government involvement so
Ben first of all you've got this public
goods nature of knowledge right so again
this is one right
think we would agree that a great deal
of the research that comes out of
universities is just not very useful
right or is actually of negative value
and then it comes down to the question
of is it worth pulling the plug on it if
only five or 10 percent of the research
is actually worthwhile this comes down
to do we have a system that is actually
capable of just a finding that five or
ten percent so accurately that it's with
that we can trust it and this is right
to say now right now furthermore I would
say that even for the research that
comes out of universities that is
clearly useful there's still the
question of where those researchers
would have been if they weren't in
universities I say a lot of them would
have ended up in the private sector and
likely would have been doing things that
were more useful in what they're doing
there is a standard view among academics
that basic research is way more socially
valuable than Applied Research however
there's been a lot of research saying
that's not really true when basic
research doesn't go anywhere and it's
the probably research that they're
complet is almost everything so Terence
Keely has a revisionist history of
science which i think is quite
compelling on these grounds and he
endures the idea that if you want to
come up with something useful you should
first try to figure out something not
useful and then hope that coincidentally
useful stuff comes out of it just seems
like a strange way to apply yourself
you're trying to find useful things all
right now on the question of Pell grants
and social justice generally all right
this is one that weighed on me quite a
bit and this is where this argument I
was giving you about credential
inflation is so crucial right because
it's very easy to go and take a look at
an individual person and see they got
some government money and this allowed
them to go to college and turn the life
of their lives around
my best friend of Princeton came from a
family so poor that they grew that he
literally built a log cabin to live in
when he was a kid all right and I have
to say like without audio this funding
will probably Princeton was so rich they
would have paid him but anyway but a lot
of people like my friend would not have
been in college but here's the thing
about crow that you need to do don't
focus on individuals focus on the system
you are creating right is true one
individual is better off when they get
government money but if everybody in a
generation has access to this money this
means that people are going to get a lot
more education and this means that
employers jack up the expectations for
how much education you need to have to
be worthy of an interview and that's the
fundamental problem right we shouldn't
be focusing on a few kids you know you
have very talented kids from poor
families and said why don't we think
about the typical kid from poor families
who no longer have the option of getting
a good job right out of high school
right in the old days you did have that
option now wasn't that just cuz the
technology was different no because the
technology hasn't change nearly enough
to explain the change the main thing
that changed that you now need a lot
more education to get any given job it's
not that we that so much that we switch
to more technically demanding jobs
that's true but it's only a small part
of the story the main thing that's
occurred in our society is now there's
so many people with college degrees the
you need a college degree to be
considered worthy of being trained for a
good job whereas in the past a high
school degree would have been fine
alright so I see in terms of social
justice I think that while it's been
very intuitively plausible to think the
government funding is supporting it if
we think about all the opportunities
that we have lost it's a different story
and again if you think about kids and
towns where a lot of people are addicted
to addicted to opioids maybe if they
could get good jobs right out of high
school things would look better for them
right maybe they looked around and saw
wow if I just finish high school then I
can get a good job then that would be
very motivating possibly all right
furthermore you know so if you really
are concerned about this as being a deep
savvy problem there is private
philanthropy edie coming from harvard i
know he knows about private philanthropy
there there there have been multiple
kana mists who have pointed out that one
of the best things to do if you're from
a poor family is applied to very top
schools because in fact places like
Harvard will probably let you in for
less money than George Mason would
seriously all right so Carolina oxb has
done a lot of this and if you just get
some practical advice here right now if
you're from a poor family apply to the
very best places because the money they
have is beyond all your imagination
alright so don't think I can't go to
harbor because I'm poor no that's where
you should go it's the perfect place to
go if you're poor alright now last one
on Jeffersons Jefferson a citizenship
this is where there is the ideal which I
strongly agree with my first book the
myth of rational voter is all about
lamenting how little Americans know
about politics and economics but here's
the thing people who go to college today
still know next to nothing about the
stuff I would love if you would make me
curriculums are and I could whip them
into shape and say you don't graduate
unless you can I need to do supply and
demand sorry all right but that
is not on the agenda not even close in
fact probably more on the agenda if
there was any centralized system was you
don't graduate if you do understand
supply and demand so I'm yeah so anyway
in the book I go over all the evidence
on the political facts of Education and
this is this is a section that actually
is just satisfying to people of almost
all ideologies because here's what I say
you know what people think of
universities is great left-wing
indoctrination camps they aren't the
students actually don't change their
minds very much probably because the
faculty is really boring and also they
don't show up to class very much all
right so put that together the actual
ideological effects of college are
greatly overrated the people that you
see on TV or shared on the internet or a
tiny minority of a tiny minority they
don't speak for anyone but themselves
they're not the voice of any generation
and they never will be so it's just
worth keeping that in mind but anyway
the other side though is that people
aren't learning much good stuff either
alright so the actual the actual level
of knowledge that college graduates have
of civics or history you can so
abysmally low it's almost impossible for
people at places like the Soho forum you
and to imagine it but again you know by
the book read it and see the depressing
truths about how little knowledge people
have now again if right now we only gave
people like six weeks on civics then I
think it'd be totally reasonable to try
Ed's approach and let's just try harder
but if you give people three or four
years this stuff and they still don't
know anything this is where I say look
apparently the system is just not very
worthwhile all right and again remember
of course who is going to be teaching
the stuff it's probably going to be the
professors that neither ed nor I or
particularly fans up I mean last thing I
do think it's a bit odd given that Ed is
concerned about keeping government away
from anything that affects the sold I
think the government would be good at
shaping citizens what kind of citizens
do you think everyone wants to shape at
all right da but anyway thank you very
much and as I said privilege to debate
with that
[Applause]
and of course it is a privilege to
debate with Brian as well so um what I'm
not I'm not gonna say anything more
about the the national education facts
just I wanna highlight that the papers
that he signs for papers that were
response to an overwhelming literature
in the early 1990s pointing out the
incredibly strong relationship between
education and and earnings nurnies drove
at the national level for which there
was a backlash which Lant Pritchett my
beloved colleague was part of but you
know that the the I think there is a
broader set of papers that that should
be should be viewed at beyond what was
in in there so now it's the important
stuff so choosing the the three
arguments that I gave which I feel
compelled to defend one of which is
choosing which which ideas lots of ideas
are negative value added I actually
don't think that's right I think I think
ideas are options and variance is good
and the bad ones just kind of disappear
or float around in humanities
departments or something and and the
good the good ones are you know the good
ones are are you know held held in I
don't mean that my friends in humanities
I deeply Revere you the the good ones
the good ones stick around I think I
think that's really right that that by
throwing a bit of money at various forms
of medical research you get a chance for
some some really game-changing
technologies and again you know yes
maybe Paul if Paul Milgram had worked
for private sector firm he would have
produced something as socially valuable
as the spectrum auction but it's hard
for me to imagine that that would have
been the case that you needed to save
someone was actually thinking about
public policy as well and I think you
know it's not like you you're it's not
like I'm necessarily sure the returns
are higher on one side versus the other
but I think the answer of having no
public funding of research that seems to
me to be too far and having a bit a bit
going in that direction seems helpful in
terms of Pell grants I think my case is
actually stronger that I don't imagine a
world in which all of a sudden
eliminating federal funding for
education is gonna bring jobs back for
guys in West Virginia who are currently
dealing with the opioid crisis does
anyone actually believe that that
actually if somehow that we gutted
federal spending for education that that
would make a West Virginia an employment
paradise that feels so far from the
reality to me
whereas it does seem that occasionally
we we enable people to get out now all
that brian says about about applying to
Harvard if you come from a disadvantaged
background I'm very grateful for the
advertisement you did for Harvard uh an
admissions department for doing that
it's absolutely true but I think no
matter what system you have that occurs
through private competition
entrepreneurship and philanthropy and we
love that I think having a little bit of
federal intervention that uses tax
dollars to provide a bit of extra
support to poor people is is is
desirable and that little bit of extra
support for poor people is not somehow
other
ratcheting up the credentials that
everyone occurs that's being determined
by much larger events in the labor
market and the demands for skill one
small Pell grant program isn't changing
that it's just making sure that a little
bit more resources are going for people
for people who have a little bit less
and I think overall in this country
having some sense that the federal
government occasionally does something
which actually is targeted in a not
totally crazy way towards poor people
isn't the craziest thing in the world
now the final point which I feel far
more tentative about which is this this
state making democracy making point and
I agree that it's it's a tenuous claim
that I'm making and let me let me be
clear if I thought it was about the
schools inducing ideology or the federal
government determining ideology I would
be totally against it I actually think
that if schools do create citizenship
it's by bringing smart people together
and having them try to deal with the
problems of making too much noise in the
dorm or you know trying to deal with you
know how is it you deal with your
cokehead friend who then is peed all
over the guys the guys think I mean this
is how democratic action Democratic
skills are built on on the streets the
but the appearance of this are really
pretty strong so if you ask yourself
which of the Warsaw Pact was sort of an
artificial thing that kept you know a
whole set of countries in an awful
condition for many many decades and then
it falls apart and some countries like
Poland in the Czech Republic turn into
reasonably well functioning democracies
another like Kazakhstan turned into
areas that are not what factor predicts
which areas managed to turn over into
democracy in which ones don't
education ok the educated countries of
Western Europe managed to do pretty well
the less educated countries do not
across you know pretty much along along
any political dimension that you look at
right education is positively correlated
with things now this doesn't mean that
the average educated person is all that
productive and I'm sure in the je of
George Mason this wasn't true right that
in fact there were plenty of people who
are graduating from William and Mary
College who were just into drinking
their tankards of ale and going home and
racing some donkeys right and had
nothing to do with anything but there
were a few there were a few guys who
actually imbibed right and as James
Madison did at Princeton University from
the Reverend James Witherspoon the cool
clean thought of the Scottish
enlightenment right which was
transferred to him and then put into our
Constitution it's hard to imagine how
that would have happened without an
educational institution that transferred
that knowledge it seems like that pretty
much makes the case right there that in
fact my you know gratitude for the US
Constitution for the limits on the
overreaching power of the state that you
know came to the pen of James Madison
from Scotland through James withers tune
at Princeton that feels like I've made
the case for at least some subsidy of
education without anything more from
there so I think I'll probably end on
that
[Applause]
I'm gonna take moderators prerogative to
ask a couple of questions but at this
stage formally you each have the
opportunity to ask each other questions
you can waive the honor or you can take
the opportunity Brian do you have a
question you want to put - ed yes okay
yeah so actually in the greenroom we
were talking about the economic case for
abolition right so you know that you
know there's a you know there's sort of
a an initial view that a lot of
economists have that look maybe you want
to cut a lot but you don't want to cut
all the way down to zero but then you
realize what wait a second if we're
gonna cut all the way down to 5% maybe
it's worth just going down to zero
because those remaining 5% just aren't
all that worthwhile this is the textbook
logic of when you wanted to shut down
your firm entirely rather than reduce
your production by 95 percent so it
seems to me that that actually the idea
of the economists idea that economists
would just economics you know it goes
against abolition is wrong so like so
others like we have water conditions
under which you would favor abolition of
anything and how is it different from
here so so that's basically a fixed cost
argument which is of course a perfectly
coherent one I think there are counter
arguments in this case first of all many
of the fixed cost to having these
programs have already been paid right so
they're not uh they're they're not ones
in which we necessarily would would
eliminate secondly you know having some
degree of public intervention enables us
to learn stuff so you know when you cut
down entirely it's like these famous
one-arm bandit problem' so I shut the
thing down entirely I've shut off all
learning about what the impacts of
public interventions are as long as I
have small amounts of stuff going on I'm
continuing to gather some degree of
knowledge about how this how this works
and just to give an example that we were
also talking about in the green room so
one of the things that I feel very
passionately about is is it's one thing
to be Pro vocational training I'm not
sure we know how vocational training
actually work well in this country and I
think the critical thing is to have
experimental programs outside of school
competitively sourced tested through
randomized control trials that generate
the knowledge which is so vital for us
to actually figure out how to how to
actually make you know make the American
workforce more productive make sure that
people who start with less end up with a
decent chance to be part of the part of
the you know the American economy right
and I guess you know for the other
question so it seems like when you're
doing international comparisons you
focus very much on this one variable
education where his eye for example for
the former Soviet Union would say look
parts the sort of the Soviet Union that
were more developed before a more
developed today parts the world war
backwards then or more backwards now so
again it seems to me that actually
normally you've got like ten good things
going together education is one of them
buddy and of course there's reverse
causation and plenty other stories so I
am puzzled as to why you were so quick
to latch on education I know you were
talking about the 1960 results now like
you know education 1960 predicts that
predicts results today but like you know
there's there's this much bigger area of
research just on long-run persistence
which seems to be weighing here so what
do you say about that
so the the education and growth I mean
we know that it's it's you know the
effects get stronger if we control for
initial initial levels of development in
terms of the education growth results
and in terms of the education
democratization results it's also true
that an initial income is not a is not a
great predictor of the of the Soviet you
have the Warsaw Pact countries
transferring but I agree with you that
you know it's it's awfully hard many
things do go together at the gross
national level now in some sense I was
inspired by your own words which are
such such a big fan of simple
transparent statistics which I believe
in and you know in most of what what you
do in the book you you adhere to that
perfectly and then you cite a bunch of
papers and macro growth that you know
which would you did not write and are no
sense responsible for but they do not
fit that that you know that definition
of simple transparent statistics and
when you do do simple transparent
statistics you get back to something
like a pretty high return to education
across countries
I say it's transparent for macro but
well you know as we know macro is a
faith-based discipline so yeah actually
that anticipates the question I had that
one of mainly put to you had as far as I
understood you you just said the richer
country gets the more it spends on
education richer regions richer richer
regions of the new US spend more on
education and richer countries spend
more on education poor countries spend
less so did you seem to say well maybe
that's just the causation it's a luxury
good you're Richard you spend more on it
so the and that it has no no causality
for for for wealth it's just that when
you're rich you spend more that's the
cause so so it's a Priora it's not
unreasonable we do know is that
education in
in 60 holding income constant or not
predict subsequent income growth income
in 1960 does not predict subsequent
education growth or to make this more
tangible the nations of East Asia Taiwan
China Japan right Singapore all began
educating like crazy investing like
crazy and education when they were poor
they are not poor any longer right and
there is no one who has looked at their
growth process and not thought that
upgrading of human capital was a serious
part of that is that I mean is there
anyone in this room can actually believe
that if you know Singapore had kept its
level of education as in 1960 or China
had as of 1970 that these countries
would be anywhere near as rich as they
are now is there anyone here actually
can you actually believe that Brian okay
go for it
tell me how it with a literacy rate of
like 20% you can achieve per capita GDP
of $35,000 the so you know there's years
of education there's actually achieving
literacy so the actual literacy numbers
suppose these countries are already fine
and they were actually I'm Bhutto
actually I've got him let me and I think
the numeracy was damn good to pull it up
I've got it yeah all right I'll hold off
on me okay well I Brian also president
ratification I think that the Chiefs can
effect wasn't mentioned a couple times I
head and fight you could you take a
little bit more time than you did to
explain what you mean by the sheepskin
effect oh yeah so you know measure the
slot experiment you're on your way to
your last final exam in college and you
get in a bike accident right and so you
missed your final exam you have a really
hard ass teacher who says sorry tough
luck you can't retake the exam what
should you do so if you think that all
that's going on in college is that
you're getting paid for skills you
acquire then you should just forget
about it it's no big deal just get out
of the hospital get well and go get your
job on the other hand if you think that
signaling is important you should be
concerned and say maybe I better go and
retake that last class so that I don't
spend my whole career with this bad mark
on my record alright so anyway so the
scenes can effect is this attempt to
measure how much extra payoff do you get
for actually crossing crossing the
graduation finish line versus merely
doing the individual years all right so
there is a lease name a moderate-sized
literature on this and in the book I go
and try to track down every single paper
on this and
take an average and you know the average
that I get is that senior year is worth
six point seven times as much as an as
one of the as an average year so
basically if you look at the average
value of years one two or three senior
year seems to be worth six point seven
six point seven times that in percentage
terms so even even more extreme right
ending and so now it is possible this is
just because it's the better students
that do mind finishing but least the
papers will they put in measures of
ability normally they find is when you
put in measures of ability it does
reduce the value of graduation but it
also reduces estimates of the value of
the individual years leaving the ratio
very similar to what I told you know so
so first of all we don't I mean there
surely is signaling involved in the
sheepskin I mean it's it's it's almost
crazy to believe that there isn't the
the the reasonable the reasonable third
view which is which is floating around a
stretch to just emphasize it is that you
know education is just correlated with
ability but which doesn't need to be
signalling so meaning that you know you
can have a positive correlation between
education and success even if your
ability level is printed on your
forehead forever and it's just more able
people are more likely to actually show
up and get their diploma which I think
in this case it's also quite plausible
that like the guys who are spending
three and a half years and not bothering
to pick up the final one there's
something there's something wrong about
them and the measures of ability that
Brian is talking about well perfectly
reasonable you know as we know they're
not they're not capturing many things
which as you say in your book are things
that employers care about which is not
being a total doofus and not bothering
to pick up your diploma after three and
a half years or tuition paying questions
and again the usual rule is try to state
your question as a question and I will
also be collecting people who are
raising their hands you have to get over
to the mic and yeah don't deliver a
speech ask question and I will be taking
questions from our live streaming
audience as well first question please
sir go ahead please ask a question
please ask question yes my question is
there are at least there's there are a
few hundred federal laws that higher
education institutions are required to
abide
by immersed in a result of taking
federal funding have there been any
estimate of what the cost of complying
with these federal laws and regulations
are and and and how does that affect the
cost benefit trade-off for universities
and for society at large
[Laughter]
too many damn rules out there okay
that's a no I I haven't I don't know if
you see I mean it's it's it's
fascinating research question I don't I
don't know the answer to this I mean all
I know is that there's just what there's
only one college that I know of that
actually doesn't take the deal and a
bunch of my students teach there and I'm
blanking on the name which is really
embarrassing
but yeah he'll still of course all right
so as far as I know he'll still is the
only college in America that says we
won't take your money because we don't
want to follow the rules and it seems
like if like if the costs were really
high there'd be more but I don't know
you know just to prove to a County cell
I was I was kind of happy that there
were rules that push Harvard to make
sure they admit students who were on
ROTC that was actually a rule that was
imposed by the federal government that I
thought I thought the idea of a bunch of
Harvard professors like me acting as if
we were superior to people who decided
to put themselves in harm's way to
protect our country was outrageous so I
was I was really quite flat pleased
actually that the federal government
today next question hi not to beat the
data disagreement to death but it seems
someone important and Brian you said
that you had you can't just look at 1960
and then look at 2010 and say oh the
countries with higher education levels
had big economic growth that's not the
right way to do it you need to make some
of these adjustments and you sort of we
have your hands like that they the hand
waving part is the adjustment total
factor productivity because wouldn't
that be the place for education show
Sigma D ed mentioned that and the
question is really what are these
adjustments and and do they meet the
standard that education is not in the
adjustment yeah yeah so they do them
either standard education is not in the
adjustment I mean here it's only alike
you know so here is the main thing that
I would say the people reef do research
in this area generally want to find a
very large effective educational
national growth and they struggle to do
it and they don't do it and to me this
is one of the things that makes a
research literature credible is if the
researchers want answer a and get not a
and they work on it for decades and they
still can't get the right answer right
now so Lant Pritchett is probably
different story right now he's more of a
contrarian yes but you know so you know
the main paper that I that I cite in the
book is there's actually one that
actually goes and redoes the standard
results with all eight known data sets
those author's own data set comes up
with a higher number and they say oh
this is what makes it good but as far as
I can tell they're the only ones who
believe their data set is particularly
good so I mean let you know the other
people who really want the answer to
come out high and they go through eight
data sets and really they find well like
a couple come up with results that are
maybe had that where the national pay
office maybe half for an individual's
and every all the other ones are less so
I mean to me that's like you know even
when you don't go and actually crack
open the box and look at everything they
did which is really hard of course that
could take decades but still if people
who want to find your result don't get
it that seems very trustworthy to me so
that's that's you know with all due
respect that's not my interpretation of
the literature you know Lance Lance
conversion which is certainly
conversions GDP into total Phatak factor
productivity is 100% using human capital
in with a negative sign in the
adjustment factor so something that has
human capital the negative sign and the
adjustment factor is being then
regressed on human capital and
unsurprisingly they're finding that
coefficient drawn down I mean it's also
true more generally that you know these
are asking the question as to whether or
not human capital generates higher
growth rates rather than just higher
levels which is a somewhat different
question and I think if you were asking
yourself whether or not is the consensus
that human capital always generates
higher growth rates I think Brian is
exactly right there's there's no
consensus on that whatsoever and that's
totally fair but the levels require
return I think it's pretty hard to look
at that data and not see that that at
least without doing a lot of adjustment
the levels is pretty strong and positive
and again just a naive stupid cross
country coefficients point for next
question for Brian given your friendship
with Robin Hanson I'm assuming you're
not arguing that we will just get rid of
signaling so I want to know are you
proposing a different better form of
signaling if so what yeah so like I said
right now we pour about 300 billion
dollars worth of government money at all
levels on the status quo so a lot of
what I would say is let's stop pouring
the money and then to see what replaces
it right Neela there are so many other
options again go big
it is just the people are going to spend
fewer years in school right and that
won't look bad anymore when a lot of
other people do it so they say we like
it is you'll say like it is true than
earlier earlier decades people actually
just spent fewer it left fewer years in
school and they were able to get a job
right out of high school and then
they're signaling to rise for the system
but even that's the much more socially
functional kind of signaling where you
live where you show that you actually
are able to do the job and you or you
signal through job performance so I
think that's a big part of it again you
know since this debate was only in
college I didn't talk about my other
stuff in high school so I mean I'm the
high school abolitionists to really at
least least government's at government
funding for it in fact yes in the you
know so it's not integral to the
argument at all but in the book I do
several times say I actually favor full
separation school and state but I think
we'll make Jean happy although make Edie
even less happy yeah but anyway so you
know you know in terms of more moderate
reforms I think just getting kids that
do not like academics to start looking
at vocational education when they're in
middle school or early in high school
would be a bit another big improvement
if you can it also writes a signal at
the same time it's providing more
genuine skill creation so you know like
really what you want to do from a social
point of view is to try to get a to for
it have people signaling and acquire
useful skills at the same time right
rather than the system we got where the
two are fairly separates Brian who's
gonna pay for that vocational training
again so this is I said this is one of
my half measures so yeah if we're just
keeping the existing system of public
education then you're just taking the
existing budget and putting it into
vocational education so that's no big
but it is there is there a given your
abolition side is there a dream that you
think that somehow this is a private or
philanthropic way that millions of
American kids are gonna get vocational
training that not any public support yes
oh yeah so in begin do you you me so
well is it so hope for him you may have
heard him at least the audience here may
have heard about education in Britain in
the u.s. in the nineteenth century and
the very high levels literacy that
Ritchie before there was significant
government money so yeah so you know
precisely because people get so upset
about the idea of poor Kubik torque is
not having education I think that
there'd be plenty of philanthropic money
course wouldn't be money for the very
wasteful education system we have right
now again we just realize they right now
we're spending like 12,000 per kid and
yet 30 years ago we were spending a tiny
for
that you even adjusting for inflation I
don't see why for very poor kids you
know the philanthropy couldn't pay for a
much more much more stripped-down
version of Education which again it's
probably a better one anyway because
back in the old days kids could play
when they weren't do it doing their
studies and like now where you're being
bossed around for eight or nine hours a
day
next question yeah and for Edie I found
your arguments very powerful I guess my
only question is there any government
program that this wouldn't similarly
apply to is there something unique about
education that makes your arguments such
that you couldn't do it for everything
else as well oh I just need the
correlations between education and
economic success at the local and
national level are vastly stronger than
for say things like you know roads and
bridges so I've long been in a you know
an infrastructure skeptic I think the
case on on America needing more
infrastructures is quite debatable
certainly when we've done things like
look at ara spending American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act spending for
infrastructure across areas in the US
we've seen very little impact on
long-run economic outcomes now that
being said I mean there is there is a
case for maintenance so you know a
little bit of work on potholes ain't the
worst thing in the world given that
you've got the stuff although in those
cases I see no reason why most road
maintenance can't be paid for by users
and you know if you just to take a more
extreme example the idea that you need
any federal transfers for things like
you know the airport that I'm about to
go to is laughable to me right you know
the average person who flies in and out
of JFK has in it has an income that's
ten times higher than the American
average why they cannot pay for whatever
their infrastructure costs are with
landing fees is completely beyond me so
you know it's particularly because
education has you know something of this
either the generating the knowledge side
like the spectrum auctions or you know
it's a way of actually targeting a that
we actually think yields benefits and
remember brian's seat at the point that
there are at least private benefits for
education right so you know the the poor
kids that are benefiting from this are
you know we're accepting that they're
actually gonna get something get
something out of this whereas I'm not
seeing any particular benefit to poor
kids by having rich kids being able to
fly for free on from through Kennedy
Airport a quick question for it so if
you want to hand out Pell grants to the
poor kids go to school should we have
some kind of grants
so that poor drivers can use the toll
roads it's it's hard probably not the
it's it's it's probably I mean if you if
you told me a story in which you know
this was somehow they're going to be
crucial for the for the guys getting a
job and conceivably but most of the time
you want people to pay for the social
cost of their actions and it's you know
schooling is a reasonable way to
redistribute funding giving people the
free the free right to pollute and
congest is not is not nearly as sensible
next question yes I was this is Fred I
was very very surprised at your comments
about Seattle but there were a number of
things you mentioned that I was somewhat
surprised about but you mentioned
Microsoft and Amazon in particular to
companies that selected Seattle almost
arbitrarily and which hire almost
entirely from outside the Seattle area
and thus neither seems like a
particularly good example of why the
local education in Seattle led to the
formation of this tech boom Amazon chose
Seattle because Jeff Beezus basically
went on a cross-country Drive and
stopped there he had started as a as as
a trader at de sha and decided that he
was going to join the dot-com boom and
Microsoft chose Seattle more or less
because Bill Gates grew up there and and
not for any other particular reason and
both hire almost most of their
workforces at least intern at the
executive level and on the tech level
come from outside the company the area I
think you forgot Starbucks but take it
away so so the it's it's not so relevant
what they do now but rather what they
did at the beginning now I've heard
repeated interviews with Jeff Bezos
where he has cited the education of the
Seattle workforce as being one of the
things when he was in his car that
partially determined where he was
locating so I have no idea how to parse
what goes on in Jeff Bezos his mind or
you know what would actually drove his
decision relative to dreaming of the
Pacific Northwest and the totem poles or
something I'd have no idea what was
fueling him but the the he certainly has
mentioned education in in numerous times
and certainly in the early days they
would not have been recruiting people
from far away they would have been they
would have been hiring people nearby in
the case of Bill Gates and and Microsoft
you know the very fact that you had
someone as you know as well trained in
is Bill Gates in Seattle to come home to
Seattle is have partially
of the fact that they had massive
computers in Seattle when he was a kid
and grew up playing with them so I think
it's you know at least it's it's a
defensible line of mine is it debatable
sure but it is also just true
statistically that they literally are on
the regression lines that they literary
doing exactly as well as you would
expect there they should be doing based
on their years of schooling comment
Brian sure so it was you know so you
know ed mentioned that you know the
social benefits of Education see me
bigger at the regional level and this is
where I say the reverse causation is
especially easy because the highly
educating people tend to go to the
booming areas of the economy right so
you know New York and Seattle and the
bay area suck up highly educated people
from other parts of the country and
here's the thing if my story is right
that would still happen because of my
stories right then the high ability
people will tend to go and have a lot of
Education which they need an order show
off and then they will go and take their
high ability and take it to these areas
of the country that are booming so you
know I would just say that's really like
both stories would predict basically the
same thing so one thing that is slightly
different is the best studies of local
wage effects look at migrants so you're
looking at wages before and after you
came to the city so it's not it's not as
if you're just comparing you know at a
cross-section the people in Seattle were
the people who are in Detroit you're
actually saying you know when someone
comes to Seattle to their wages go up
and the answer is they do and and you
see them going up not in a single time
wage jump but you know year by year
month by month they experience faster
wage growth which is sort of compatible
with the view that in you know in a city
like Seattle people are learning from
the people around them which is the very
essence of the human capital externality
viewpoint but there are also other other
viewpoints which are compatible with the
with the individual ability of viewpoint
as well next question so America puts in
a lot of money into education high
school education and higher education
but our literacy and numeracy rates
across the the world are to say the
least not not good can both of you speak
to the countries that are R&E know the
top five or the top ten in terms of
literacy and numeracy and of what they
do in terms of funding education yeah so
in terms of the facts totally agree with
you so in my book I put a lot of effort
into tracking down evidence on what
American adults know because the other
the standard way that
measuring educational outcomes is to
give someone a final exam or an exit
test and even the problem with this as
any psychologist will tell you is people
forget stuff right a lot of stuff in
fact people tend to forget almost
everything they don't use after a few
years so anyway these tests of what
American adults knows are you know like
to me or what what the real measure of
like education accomplishments are and
yeah I think so you know there's - there
have been two big national tests of
American adults literacy and numeracy
and both of them lined up saying that
American adult that maybe about a third
of American adults are barely literate
and numerate which seems like a terrible
result for a country where we're putting
in so much money per year and we're
spending so many years in terms of other
countries so the u.s. is close to the
highest spending per student in the
world right and I think we're now about
average in terms of years that we spend
in school for rich rich countries so you
know I'm like so Italy in terms of like
what other countries are doing better oh
so you know probably part of it is just
their students start out better honestly
i South Korean students probably start
out better than American students so the
day they arrive in school they're
probably they're probably already doing
better and literate in literacy and
numeracy terms of teaching quality it
seems plausible to me they got better
teaching quality although I'm getting
remember Finland which also does great
they don't even start school till seven
and they don't seem to be very into
testing at all which is pretty amazing
so you know you know the question is
like you know do I think that I could go
and improve literacy numeracy if you put
me in charge then yeah all right which I
get them like mostly just by putting a
lot more time on task so when I go and
look at the curriculum for K through 12
schools in my area and to see that
you're spending over half of your school
day on non-academic material and then
realize there's plenty kids who still
can barely read and write it's like stop
doing that no art and music until you
can read and write
obviously like this is crazy to go and
have them going and seeing and chorus
when they can't do it when they can't
add but but here's the thing I have no
optimism that these but these even very
basic proposals will be adopted by cuz
I've been to a parent-teacher night and
I've seen how they think the like if I
were to say this they would just look at
me like something they scraped off the
bottom of their shoe like that this is
not like they said I think we could do
both well you haven't
they'll say I learned to shut up a long
time ago but yeah yeah yeah I mean we
disagree only that I'm much less
tolerant of this stuff than Brian is so
the but I can't look at the the problems
of us K through 12 or the places that
have been more successful you know
Singapore South Korea and think the
right answer is just to just to say no
that just doesn't feel at all like the
right answer to me that that maybe there
are areas in which we have to do less
public there may be an areas in which we
need to do more competitive voucher
provided services of different forms but
I can't look at America and think the
right answer is let's just shut down
public funding for education then
everything will be hunky-dory that just
feels completely not right to me and I
don't I don't think that I can see
you'll see an example in the world where
that that looks right to me
so by all means let's admit our failings
and Brian's been great on this lets you
know question every nonsense assumption
that we handle around and Ryan's been
great on this but I don't think the
right answer is to give up on a public
commitment to trying to actually make
sure our children actually learned
something so again I don't think things
will be hunky-dory if you listen to me
I think we'll just stop wasting a ton of
money alright it's very different so I
mean I'm not saying that they'll just
build more - they're just build more
mana rails and stupid places Brian
that's a that's a strange political
economy model I mean maybe there'll be a
few more stupid monorails but I think
also they'll be some deficit reduction
there'll be some tax reduction you know
probably know there'll be some more
roads so again like I will say that when
I look at roads like even though they're
not causing economic growth at least you
can drive so that's nice you know like
when when I see people on when you wait
when you build a new road look at the
drivers they seem happy whereas when I
go to look at across the classroom the
students seem sad next question ask the
college students I can attest for all
terrible people that's besides the point
you're victims not terrible people so I
know that a lot of corporations spend a
lot of money on education McDonald's
recently giving out over a hundred
million per year for sending their
employees back to get educated a lot of
companies require MBAs for high level
positions there's a question to both
useless differently to add aren't these
examples of private companies covering
the cost of education especially
targeting the poor and Bryan isn't this
a case of corporations paying for more
education after they already have
employees you can see their value at
work and saying more education adds more
value even after we can already evaluate
them so we do not need to have a
credential to just measure their value
yeah that's a great question so the easy
answer for me is to say MBA is unlike
most of the other stuff are super useful
however I've talked to way too many MBAs
who tell me that's completely wrong so
then I've got to come up with another
story and you know say whatever you
think about this this is such a this is
a small percentage of a small percentage
so I wouldn't put too much weight on it
but even the o best story that I've got
is that even after you've been working
in a firm in a subordinate role there's
still a lot of uncertainty about whether
you got the right stuff to be management
whether you aren't management material
and I think that's a lot of what's going
on is that they offer these MBA programs
to see who has the real ambition who's
really determined to go and do a second
job at night in order to rise in this
company and who can be offered this deal
and just say I don't feel like it so I
think that the you know there is this
this useful secondary signaling that's
going on but again maybe the MBA really
is teaching useful stuff it's just that
having of which again I'm very open to
accept that everyone I know with
first-hand experience says that's wrong
it was a great question I think that you
know they're both good theoretical
reasons and empirical reasons to think
that McDonald's educating a few of its
workers isn't gonna you know solve
America's under education problem now
it's it's an example of a case in which
firms actually do value skills and they
are willing to to put some money into it
but you know many of the benefits of
upskilling accrue to the worker not to
the firm which is a good reason why
firms are at least thought to under
invest if they're if they're the only
entities that invest in in their
schooling and just as it as a
quantitative share the overall firms
paying for education across the country
is fairly small that being said I think
you know I'm all for more engagement
with employers to make sure that skilled
providers are actually doing something
that will actually deliver a job and I
think we have a number of examples in
which this is yielded relatively
positive results so I think the right
answer is again not to trust
entirely to employers but to figure out
some some more hybrid model that uses
the information created by employers to
actually deliver deliver employable
skills a quick comment on that so ed
just repeated but I think it's Gary
Becker's greatest mistake which is that
private employers do not have an
incentive to train their workers in
general skills because the worker can
just take the skills and go someplace
else that was that would be true that's
true unless employers can have you work
for a lower wage when you're being
trained which they totally can all right
the only exception really is for workers
that what would need to earn less the
minimum wage therefore college students
we do have this great loophole where
you're allowed to work for free you
can't work for a dollar less than wage
but you can work for free if you're
getting training for a college type job
there's a lot of people were angry about
this and want to apply the minimum wage
to the trail you know to Chhotu interns
as well I say really we should expand it
so that everyone can work for free and
why is it so great to be able to offer
free cuz you get something useful you
get an actual practical job training and
again to me the moral outrage at
employers who go and and don't pay you
anything when you're working for them is
bizarre given that colleges could charge
seventy thousand a year to go and give
you a lot less and people don't complain
about that yeah I think on the policy
side actually we we largely agree I
think in terms of just the current the
current status quo the minimum wage is a
binding commitment for McDonald's
employees we're gonna be given some
extra training so in fact there is there
is this lower bound that makes it hard
for them to pay for it by getting lower
wages
well the BLS could just reinterpret its
internship or its engine some paid
internships rules which are already a
giant loophole that you can drive a
truck through so why not let them drive
two trucks through it
hi Brian I just wanted to ask you how do
you disappoint the entire libertarian
party with only one let oh sorry you
don't understand how do you support the
entire libertarian party with only one
leppe oh I don't know what Aleppo is
yeah exactly
my point is okay I'm not sure if you got
that gay Gary Johnson said he didn't
know what Aleppo was either but my point
is that currently unfortunate I mean I
heard you speak on the Rubin report
about sort of your your min arcus -
anarchist views and I thought that was
really interesting I think unfortunately
the Libertarian Party is in kind of a
rough spot right now where it's hard to
be taken seriously I do oh I'm getting
there yeah so so okay so my question is
I've heard you disgusted that there's
like this idea of the Liberto Pia where
you get you know what you'd like to
abolish what you're saying we'd like to
you know full of abolition what I'm
interested in is given the fact that
you're saying that 50 to 80% is
signaling and there's a lot less you
know sort of human capital going on
what's the what's the place for sort of
taking that and instead of trying to
push so much standard education which in
standard educational material just push
more social-emotional learning to reduce
sort of gang violence violence tribalism
all these all the other things that are
occurring with kids in public school
systems I'm sorry to say Brian that
you're gonna have to answer that
question in your summary statement
because we've run out of time to the
questions I know Brian's going to be
around signing books and answering
questions and unfortunately they have to
go but we will hear from Ed in terms of
his summary and is the negative so he
goes last Brian you go first with your
summary
hmmm alright so I began by saying that
we got the intellectual range from A to
B here I think we more have liked the
intellectual range from like a A to D or
maybe even like a to G so the additional
reason being ed and I are actors
actually I would say seemed to be quite
a bit bigger in a way actually if I
believe what II D seems to believe I
would be probably much more Pro and he
is because if it really were true that a
year of Education we're increasing a
national income by 50 percent that's a
really impressive game that's far
outside of the realm of almost anything
else that's known so I guess that Edie
doesn't quite take the estimates as
literally as he was saying but you know
you know so if you really did think that
then it would seem that he would be
quite a bit more different than I
thought for me that I am again just
going back to the miracle work you know
you like you know the main thing I can
say about that is it's very hard for a
layman to go and evaluate the actual
quality of the work independently it's
even hard for a researcher very often if
you were to go and email the researchers
and say please give me all your data and
all your work they'll to say I did it 20
years ago sorry the dog ate it that's it
I mean they're like the main thing that
I can say here in terms of convincingly
establishing the reliability of the
results I'm telling you is that the
researchers didn't want to find these
small results and they found they were
and what do people do when they get
results they don't want they try it a
different way and they look around is
there something wrong with the data they
go scrutinizing it is there some other
way that we could somehow find it and in
the end say uh I guess I just had to
publish this and like hope someone else
finds a mistake so you know you know so
I would say that like out out of people
who have actually gone through this I
mean like the people that I could find
you know like there was a very strong
consensus that the social benefits of
education are a lot less than the
private contrary to its heads telling
you and then the main disagreement was
about the interpretation again I would
say the most popular interpretation is
our data sucks and we are looking for
better data right and furthermore I
actually found that there are a couple
people in print said we will know when
we got the good data based upon whether
it gives us a high number all right so I
think this does give you an idea about
the level of motivated reasoning and the
fact that they're not getting it so I
think does establish that the result is
pretty solid
on you bad ideas being harmless options
hmm well there's a whole lot of academic
ideas that have that have worked out
very negatively so I'm not gonna blame
Edie for Marxism but it's just
worthwhile saying there's a whole lot of
universities that did promote this stuff
and it did work out very poorly and yeah
I'm really not gonna blame it for not
system but Hitler did really well with
Nazi partly the unit why not Nazi
professors of course but with you German
university professors did really well
for them also again now does this mean
that it always works out this way now
but I think the idea that there's just a
lot of poisonous ideas that come out of
academia is reasonable I think in a lot
of the you know of you know like those
you know a lot of hostility to markets
has come out of academia which again I
think both ed and I and most the
audience here will agree is a bad thing
and you know also very striking that
many of the negative ideas can die and
then they come back a zombie ideas
something like rent control is a new
idea again but you might have thought in
the 70s and 80s kill it yes and now it's
alive again and a good part of this is
to be a good part of the responsibility
does come from not economists at least
but from keybord other other social
science departments let's rethus a
second look I found a town somewhere
where didn't seem to destroy everything
so let's let's consider that yes so
begin to repeat I don't claim that
things will be hunky-dory people listen
to me and I don't think the my proposal
would revive West Virginia but I'll say
the whole country did it West Virginia
wouldn't get worse and we would save a
ton of money right any and that money
could be spent on a wide variety of
things could be spent on libertarian
things like tax cuts and deficit
reduction or a course could be spent on
all of the other things that people
might want to consider could be spent on
increasing transfer payments or it could
be spent on how about this how about you
know there is a bonus if you are a young
male from a poor family who never goes
to jail before the age of 30 you could
try something like that there could be a
bonus if you are a young female from a
poor family and you don't have a child
until you're 25 right there are a lot of
different ways that you could spend this
money in a way that would be a lot more
fruitful than ones we do if that's what
you want to do now I'm enough of a
libertarian to say that's not what I
think we see spending the money on I
think we should be focusing on tax cuts
and deficit reduction but again if you
are concerned about the things that Ed's
cancer
with there's still no reason not to go
full abolition all for education spent
over offer for higher education spending
and think about a much more constructive
way of spending the money so I will stop
there thanks a lot sir brian is probably
right there's probably a little bit more
distance than I and I suggested but I
think the largest point of distance is
that you know no matter how much you
think that we should cut and I'm
certainly on board with cutting a fair
amount there is still a vital need to
make education in this country better
there's a vital need to invest in
smarter ways of doing schooling both for
kids for vocational training for
teenagers and at the higher ed level
there's a need for improving the quality
of research funding that we do all of
this is first stage on the agenda and I
think in most of the cases the social
returns just for us as thinkers or at
least as high for trying to contribute
on having to make how to make education
better rather than just how to cut
education I will make this point larger
for the country as well that I think
very often we end up in this country in
a very you know facile debate about more
government versus less government
there's no question on that debate I'm
on the less government side of it but I
always think that you know the harder
question and in some sense the more
important question is how the heck are
we gonna get better government and in
the case of schools I think that
requirement is absolutely paramount
because in fact when our schools fail
they fail our children Andy they fail
our country and you don't need to
believe a 42 percent national return to
a year of schooling which I certainly do
not believe right my point was just in
fact that when you do the simple naive
thing you don't get something that's
small you get something that's huge but
you know that type of thing at least
makes me think that caring about
education is important now the second
point which is about bad ideas yes there
are bad ideas that are absolutely
catastrophic Marx was not a university
professor to be clear and indeed there's
a certain sense in which I'm gonna
resort to Brian's own book which is that
the university system you know is far
more likely to create indifferent
mediocrity than enormous ly powerful
evil okay enormously powerful evil
doesn't typically get tenure it doesn't
get through peer review it doesn't you
know we're as indifferent mediocrity
that's perfect for those folk those bar
so the the the you know the the point
being that in fact I think most of the
ideas that are bad that actually come
out of the university are are fairly
fairly indifferent can be jettisoned and
in fact even the rent control point
that's really not a university idea that
comes out of housing advocates in in New
York in the first part of the twentieth
century and there are some academics who
favor it but overall the big supporters
of rent control are people who have
rented units and who want the prices to
be cut down and and it's not it's not
particularly tricky to get to that just
just ending on you know I think I
actually want to end on a slightly
different note which is yeah we've been
making a lot of fun of colleges and
universities and I think there's plenty
to make fun of but I will say actually
that I feel extraordinarily privileged
to teach the students that I teach and I
actually feel extraordinarily privileged
to be part of the teaching relationship
that I am I am in with them and the fact
that I learned from them all the time so
I I you know I just feel required to say
this I'm not making a public policy
statement that comes out of that but
personally I just wanted to make it
clear given that this argument has been
and you know and I will make fun of many
things about Harvard forever and much of
Harvard deserves to be made fun of but I
don't think the students do both the
graduate students that I feel
extraordinarily lucky to work with to
learn from to collaborate with on the
research process and the undergraduates
why I feel extraordinarily privileged to
teach and to work with that has been an
incredible blessing in my life and I
think it would be remissed to leave the
stage without giving giving that the
impression of that of that sense of
gratitude so let me just end there by
but you know and and just say that you
know this this kind of argument is kind
of debate this kind of thing is
absolutely vital for the future of the
republic and you know Bryan Caplan is
wonderful and is willingness to charge
into things that you know people people
throw stuff at him for and you know we
need a whole lot more of that and the
fact that I take away the answer is
being I wanna I'm happy cutting a whole
bunch of educational spending but I want
to spend at least as much effort on
trying to make education education
better without eliminating all public
role doesn't mean that I'm not very
grateful and very respectful for what
Bryan has contributed and I'm grateful
to all of you for being here as well so
thank you
[Applause]
okay we are now going to open the final
vote on the resolution or government
support of higher education should be
abolished Jane how are we doing on the
voting it looks like we're closing the
voting so please bring the results to us
to me okay so the yes votes were 50.5%
see Bryan you started was 50.5% and you
went to 63% so you picked up twelve
point six percentage points Edie was at
25% and he stayed at 25% so looks like
you win the tootsie roll